a
[Música]
i
desde el 2001 la oficina de asuntos
políticos militares del departamento de
estado de eeuu ha invertido más de 110
millones de dólares para ayudar a
destruir más de 13 millones de armas y
50.000 toneladas de municiones y otras
armas convencionales en todo el mundo y
en eeuu sin embargo en lo que va del
2021 se han reportado 343 tiroteos en
este país y 23 mil 65 personas han
muerto precisamente por causa de armas
de fuego esto se común el archivo de
violencia armada a esto hay que sumarle
también los 20 mil 668 heridos que
registra este portal por otra parte la
encuesta sobre armas pequeñas estima que
en el mundo hay aproximadamente 1100
millones de armas de fuego en las calles
de las cuales 857 millones están en
manos de civiles fuentes en eeuu dicen
que la mitad de estas armas de fuego las
poseen civiles estadounidenses
[Música]
en los últimos años rusia ha ocupado el
segundo lugar en cuanto a producción
mundial de armas el país tiene 17
millones de pistolas y rifles y rusia-
quiere ahora aumentar las medidas de
control el presidente ruso vladimir
putin ha promulgado un proyecto de ley
que endurece los controles sobre la
posesión de armas es la respuesta del
gobierno a un tiroteo mortal en una
escuela el pasado mes de mayo siete
niños y dos maestras murieron la nueva
norma establece restricciones
adicionales sobre la posesión de armas
anteriormente a las personas condenadas
por delitos graves se les prohibía
poseer un arma ahora cualquier persona
condenada o investigada por consumo de
drogas se le puede negar una licencia de
armas también se van a imponer
prohibiciones temporales a las personas
a las que se les descubra conduciendo
bajo los efectos del alcohol los rusos
con dos o más antecedentes penales
tampoco recibirán una licencia para
poseer armas de fuego
[Música]
desde que ha llegado al poder el
presidente jair bolsonaro ha intentado
facilitar el acceso de los brasileños a
las armas de fuego sin embargo el
congreso ha rechazado sus decretos que
pretendían flexibilizar el porte de
armas pero aún así ha habido leyes
aprobadas que permiten que los
brasileños puedan comprar más armas más
municiones e incluso armas más potentes
como fusiles semiautomáticos
tradicionalmente destinados a las
fuerzas armadas la consecuencia es que
el año pasado fueron registradas 180.000
nuevas armas es decir un 91 por ciento
más que el año anterior también ha
crecido espectacularmente la importación
de armas extranjeras un dos mil
quinientos sesenta por ciento en un año
y también la venta de municiones que ha
aumentado un 24% en la era bolsonaro
[Música]